le ministre de la défense inspectent les
soldats français stationnés en afrique
paris veut ainsi montrer sa
détermination face à l'offensive au
libyenne au tchad les réfugiés bien
encombrant baby doc réclament le statut
de réfugié politique en france la france
qui cherche plus que jamais à s'en
débarrasser de nouvelles révélations sur
la catastrophe de la navette américaine
les ennuis avaient commencé dès les
premières secondes du vol
il était prévisible et puis le 10ème
heures prière du couple sadique s'est
terminée dans le sang l'homme a été
abattu par les gendarmes
sa compagne a été arrêté madame monsieur
bonsoir la france ne laissera pas les
mains libres à kadhafi au tchad c'est ce
soir une certitude assortie d'une
interrogation
va-t-on vers un nouvel engagement
français aux côtés des troupes
régulières d'hissène habré
la réponse est oui oui pour le matériel
les livraisons d'armes se sont
d'ailleurs intensifié ces dernières
heures
reste une autre question celle de
l'engagement éventuel des troupes
françaises dans cette affaire le
ministre de la défense paul quilès a
d'ailleurs respecté aujourd'hui les
soldats français qui sont installés en
afrique
il rendra compte au chef de l'état dans
les heures qui viennent en tout cas la
situation est suivie de très près à part
bruno alb voici les troupes de goukouni
oueddei le chef des rebelles qui
disputent le pouvoir au président
hissène habré ces images datent de 83 de
l'époque où fut déclenché leurs
dernières tentatives appuyées par la
limite est stoppé par l'opération manta
ce soir il est difficile de préciser la
situation au tchad c'est une guerre de
communiqués qui tous montrent pourtant
que les affrontements se déroulent dans
la zone la plus critique du tchad la
zone rouge fixée par la france la limite
que les rebelles ne peuvent franchir
sous peine de déclencher son
intervention
boukous ni oueddei prétend avoir conquis
au sud de cette ligne une position
stratégique à 300 km de n'djamena
si c'était vrai il ne se trouverait qu'à
une journée de la capitale n'djamena le
président hissène habré dément que cette
position soit tombé il affirme même
avoir reconquis la ville d'oum chalhoub
en mai l'ambassadeur du tchad a pris à
paris dénonce une agression soutenu par
la libye et souhaite que paris
interviennent en afrique
la france dispose de bases militaires au
sénégal au gabon et surtout en
centrafrique où paul qu'il est ministre
de la défense s'est rendu aujourd'hui
après avoir rencontré hissène habré il a
pu vérifier sur place le dispositif
français 12 cents soldats entraînés au
combat en afrique
des hélicoptères des blindés légers et
des appareils jaguar d'appui au sol en
83 et 84 ses troupes ont formé
l'essentiel de l'infrastructure de
l'opération manta
à son retour en france paul quilès
pourra donner son évaluation de la
situation au président de la république
mais d'ores et déjà le gouvernement est
disposé à tenir ses engagements france a
pris des engagements à l'égard du tchad
ses engagements ils seront tenus quelle
que soit la période
qu'il s'agisse d'une période électorale
ou d'une période non électorale en libye
par un mot de cette affaire edwards lors
qu'à défier d'ailleurs tout ça c'est
évident mais il a quand même bien choisi
son moment
écoutez ça n'est pas évidemment un
hasard que ces opérations ont été
lancées en ce moment l'objectif des
opposants au régime de hissène habré est
de déstabiliser djamena et au delà de
djamena de déstabiliser le tchad et de
le faire pour provoquer son tuteur la
france tout cela étant bien entendu
piloté par le voisin du nord par kadhafi
kadhafi qui a fait un calcul très simple
nous sommes en france à un mois des
élections françois mitterrand ne peut
pas se permettre aujourd'hui de faire la
moindre erreur dans un domaine la
politique étrangère dont il est le seul
responsable et donc kadhafi de se dire
je balaye l'accord franco libyen de 84
la rencontre entre est avec françois
mitterrand et on verra bien
ce que sera paris et il faut bien
reconnaître que si ce pari est dangereux
il est très mal parce qu'il oblige
françois mitterrand à réagir d'une façon
ou d'une autre
en tenant compte de notre échéance
électorale baby doc que joue la montre
jamais paris nathan souhaitait son
départ d'autant qu'à sommet francophone
s'ouvrant début de semaine chez nous du
coup eh bien on aimerait bien que l'ex
président à vie et quitter le pays avant
cette date lundi le conseiller spécial
du président de la république que guy
penne a même fait accrocher par le
libéria pour convaincre les autorités de
ce pays d'accueillir jean-claude
duvalier
mais l'ancien dictateur ne l'entend pas
de cette oreille puisqu'il vient de
demander le statut de réfugié politique
en france
il a fait savoir aux journalistes qui
sont présents à talloires où il réside
en haute savoie
parmi eux notre envoyé spécial roland
sicard en demandant officiellement le
statut de réfugié pour lui et ses
proches jean claude duvalier mais
clairement les points sur les i je suis
en france
j'ai l'intention d'y rester pourtant au
départ le délai au-delà duquel l'ancien
dictateur haïtien devrait avoir quitté
la france avait été fixé à 8 jours sans
qu'il ait jamais été envisagé de lui
accorder le statut de réfugié
réservé aux victimes de la répression
dans les états totalitaires
pendant ces huit jours le gouvernement
français a multiplié les démarches
auprès des pays susceptibles
d'accueillir son hôte encombrant maroc
sénégal gabon et enfin liberia le
liberia qui n'a toujours pas donné de
réponse définitive
le gouvernement français se retrouvent
donc maintenant dans l'embarras baby doc
est toujours en france alors que s'ouvre
lundi le sommet des chefs d'état
francophones sommet auquel participeront
les nouveaux maîtres d'haïti ceux là
même qui ont succédé à jean claude
duvalier
en fait les informations recueillies sur
place ici à talloires semble indiquer
que duvalier bien décidé à jouer la
montre et que quel que soit le résultat
des négociations avec les pays d'accueil
il fera tout pour rester en france et
puis toujours à propos de cette affaire
la visite de christian nucci le ministre
de la coopération qui devait partir
aujourd'hui en haïti
cette visite a été annulé sans
explication difficile donc de dire ce
soir si c'est une conséquence de la
présence en france de baby doc ou plus
simplement de la situation politique sur
place dans l'île
l'actuel gouvernement est soumis à de
très vives critiques on lui reproche
notamment de faire la part trop belle
aux anciens notables duvaliériste
le reportage sur place de notre envoyé
spécial jean claude parisse une semaine
après le départ de leur président à vie
que les journaux haïtien host appelé
aujourd'hui baby doc
les haïtiens n'en finissent pas de
savourer une liberté retrouvée
voire même pour beaucoup jamais connu
car duvalier père et fils régnait depuis
28 ans ils n'en reviennent pas d'avoir
le droit de marcher sur le trottoir
devant le palais et même de pouvoir
toucher les grilles qui sont nombreux
d'ailleurs à repartir avec une branche
d'arbre
ils se sentent libres et cette liberté
ils sont bien décidés surtout les jeunes
en profiter le fait qu'à l'exception
d'un tous les ministres et participer à
un titre ou un autre à l'ancien régime
fait dire à certains on a repris les
mêmes
ça risque donc de recommencer il faut
que et nous avons un gouvernement
provisoire un gouvernement civil
provisoire est représentée par tous les
secteurs de l'opposition
ça me fait beaucoup mal si le jackpot
sit go
à la série joue travaille toujours sur
moi redit que le matap et parties
s'accusent y restera il faudra attendre
que le conseil se dit ici mais on peut
faire confiance à région on peut faire
confiance à qui l'on dit et on est
obligé de les croire mais s'ils
s'avisent de paix entre le sud qu'ils
ont dit on est des chicaneries un des
partis d'opposition réclament même déjà
la démission de l'actuel cabine
cette information dis-je est une insulte
à tout ce peuple vaillant qui a lutté
quel collaborateur de duvalier qui peut
établir sans hésiter la met sur la
conscience sont notés tesson un tt ou
son hymne au son innocence de tout ce
qui s'est passé en haïti pendant 28 ans
les partisans du nouveau pouvoir qui
tient conseil tous les jours dans
l'ancien palais présidentiel explique la
présence d'anciens duvaliériste par
nécessité on m'a expliqué qu'un des
ministres serait là le seul à bien
connaître tous les dossiers de l'état et
qu'un autre devrait son poste simplement
à sa bonne connaissance des comptes en
banque de la famille duvalier et de ceux
de l'état de haïti dit il n'y a rien qui
soit complètement blane il sera
complètement noir
il faut bien commencer avec les teams
on essaie dossier les types qui étaient
là hier c'est un type qui sont
indispensables pour assurer cette
continuité sinon on ne pourrait pas
aller chercher comme ça les gens à la
rue bouvier bon voici où vous êtes
ministre suzanne michaud est là et le
reprenne le pays
ici il faut compter avec l'église c'est
elle qui a aidé à défaire le régime
duvalier et c'est par une grand messe en
plein air à gonaïves la ville symbole de
la lutte que les haïtiens on fêtait la
liberté retrouvée
le serment de monseigneur gaillot un des
évêques de l'île été ressentie comme un
appel au calme et à la patience
d'une certaine façon comme une caution à
l'actuel pouvoir
mais l'église d'haïti n'est pas unanime
dans sa bienveillance à l'égard des
nouveaux dirigeants
les jeunes et le peuple a en fait la
révolution
mais on al'impression vraiment que je ne
sois pas les acteurs mais s'ils y ont
mis en place ce gouvernement provisoire
que nous avons maintenant un mois dans
ce sens là et on peut pas leur donner
tort aux gens qui disent qu on a fait la
révolution
pendant la rouler avec la réouverture de
l'aéroport le régime grossi devoir faire
face au retour des exilés
nombre d'entre eux sont bien décidés à
revenir pour se venger les autorités
espèrent éviter une nouvelle vague de
violences et de règlements de comptes
en filtrant les retours avec un système
de visa comme le faisait l'ancien régime
mais pour d'autres raisons
mais l inverse cette mesure va apporter
de l'eau au moulin de ceux qui trouvent
que le changement ne va pas assez vite
en haïti en france alors que politique
et sondages bat la campagne le discours
politique proprement dit prend parfois
le chemin des écoliers
on suit de très près vous l'imaginez les
déplacements du chef de l'état monsieur
mitterrand dont les déclarations ces
dernières semaines ont relancé les
discussions autour de la cohabitation il
était aujourd'hui dans la nièvre
un voyage régional est en principe sans
application politique mais françois
mitterrand c'est quand même livré à
quelques confidences auprès des
journalistes qui l'accompagnaient
parmi eux pascal guimier et jacou bertin
par in over nevers paris une ligne que
le pression de la république que les
parker député de la nièvre pendant 35
ans mais aussi fils chef de gare de
bonnes raisons sans doute pour françois
mitterrand d'inaugurer une gare de
nevers refaite à neuf pèlerinage pour le
président de la république bref retour
aux sources mais aussi un train de
petites confidences distillées dans le
wagon présidentielle la campagne
électorale terne françois mitterrand
répond c'est parce que les hommes
politiques répète toujours la même chose
l'aspect présidentielle de ces élections
du 16 mars
c'est vrai reconnaît le président les
législatives se déroule entièrement sous
le signe des présidentielles on y était
dès le premier jour sous-entendu dès le
11 mai 1981 la cohabitation françois
mitterrand n'élude pas la question je
peux nommer qui je veux à matignon on
réaffirme et il reste à savoir si le
parlement pourra le supporter reste à
savoir aussi si à l'assemblée
ils pourront se supporter entre eux un
coup de griffe pour le position terminus
voilà pour la marque pour les
confidences autant de petites phrases
qu'il faut quand même décoder ce soir
oui absolument ses confidences se fait
aux journalistes qui rapporte tout c'est
leur métier ne sont pas innocentes
mine de rien le chef de l'état est en
train de définir un code de bonne
cohabitation il le fait par petites
touches en 10 kg en quelques mots bien
choisis
mais tous ces mots rassembler
comme dans un puzzle permettent
d'imaginer le paysage politique si
l'opposition gagne le 16 mars
c'est un exercice inédit qui coïncide
avec une situation inédite mais qui a
pour but d'accréditer l'idée d'une
coexistence possible entre un président
de gauche et un premier ministre de
droite
mine de rien deux autres hommes font eux
aussi entre deux meetings
cette pédagogie de la cohabitation
jacques chirac et valéry giscard
d'estaing
elle consiste à fixer les règles du jeu
qui peuvent satisfaire tout le monde
soif évidemment raymond barre et on peut
sans prendre trop de risques les énoncés
en politique extérieure le président de
gauche et le premier ministre de droite
inventerait la théorie du pouvoir
partager il pourrait aller par exemple
ensemble à tokyo au sommet des pays
industrialisés
en politique intérieure le nouveau
gouvernement s'il est soutenu par sa
majorité parlementaire pourrait
appliquer son programme
à condition de ne pas toucher aux acquis
sociaux seuil minimum de consensus
si ces règles du jeu sont respectées la
cohabitation réussira mais si l'un des
partenaires quels qu'ils soient à la
tentation de les enfreindre ce jeu pour
le moins singulier se terminera plutôt
prévu mine de rien la septième chaîne
est officiellement née elle sera
culturelle publique et européennes elle
diffusera ses premiers programmes l'été
prochain par le canal des chaînes
publiques mais il faudra attendre le
satellite c'est à dire 87 pour la
diffusion à l'échelle européenne
matignon a donc tranché hier en faveur
du projet proposé par bernard faivre
d'arcier ou détriment de celui de pied
des groupes qui était plus ambitieux
mais aussi dit on plus coûteux
le nombre d'emplois salariés toujours à
la baisse c'est pour l'année passée pour
85 les chiffres ont été rendus publics
aujourd'hui par le ministère du travail
une baisse c'est qui est néanmoins plus
ralenti puisque en 85 80 mille emplois
ont été supprimés dans l'industrie et
dans les services contre 240 mille ans
84 et 200000 en 1983 la fin de la cavale
du couple maudit il est mort
elle a été arrêtée voici plusieurs jours
que les gendarmes étaient à la poursuite
de marque fasquelle et de jocelyne
bourdin qui s'était illustré par des
prises d'otages des viols et un meurtre
la fère s'est donc terminée dans le sang
aujourd'hui près de montauban
frédéric astou
cette femme est bété visiblement à bout
de nerfs c'est jocelyne bourdin pour
elle comme pour son compagnon marc
fasquelle la folle cavale de dix jours à
travers la france s'est terminée
aujourd'hui peu avant midi à l'entrée
d'un petit village du tarn et garonne
depuis la fin de la matinée les
gendarmes qui avaient mis en place un
important dispositif avait repéré la
voiture des fugitifs à montauban
quelques dizaines de minutes plus tard
la renault 25 conduit par fasquelle fini
par se trouver nez à nez avec une 4 l de
la gendarmerie à l'entrée de bombardier
en voulant faire demi tour
fasquelle percute l'avant de la voiture
des gendarmes ceci ouvre alors le feu en
direction de la renault 25 touchés
grièvement à la tête
marc fasquelle ses cadres qui s'est fait
percuté son véhicule a été obligé de
sortir son arme de défense et l individu
qui en tout état de cause étaient en
train de faire marche arrière s'échappe
et marque fasquelle qui n'a pas eu le
temps d'utiliser le pistolet poser en
permanence à côté de lui est mort peu
après dans l'hélicoptère chargé de le
transporter à l'hôpital avec sa compagne
jocelyne bourdin
ils étaient accusés d'être les auteurs
d'une dizaine d'enlèvements et de viols
de femmes dans le nord et dans le sud
ouest de la france
s'il avait libéré leurs deux dernières
victimes au début de la semaine
il aurait cependant assassiné deux
autres femmes le 3 et le 10 février
dernier
non sans leur avoir fait subir les mêmes
sévices des actes dont jocelyne bourdin
qui est actuellement gardé à vue à la
gendarmerie de castelsarrasin va
désormais devoir répondre seule une
indication préoccupante à propos du sida
en france d'après une étude menée dans
plusieurs prisons françaises
des centaines des deux détenus ont le
virus du sida ils ont sont ce que l'on
appelle séropositifs ce qui veut dire
qu'ils ont été contaminés par le virus
mais qu'ils n'ont pas pour autant la
maladie mais surtout il apparaît très
précisément que ce sont les toxicomanes
qui sont ainsi touchés et toxicomane qui
représente 10 à 30% de la population
carcérale
alors maintenant les explications de
notre spécialiste pierre lit dans les
prisons françaises plus de la moitié des
détenus toxicomanes seraient contaminées
par le virus du
da c'est un article publié par le monde
qui l'affirment il s'appuie sur une
étude faite par des médecins de la
prison de bordeaux gradignan
mais cette information est contestée par
les ministères de la justice et de la
santé qui estime que cette comptabilité
repose sur des données trop restreinte
les pouvoirs publics indique que si le
dépistage du virus n'est pas
systématique en prison il peut néanmoins
être entrepris à la demande des détenus
et qu'il se généralise lors de
l'incarcération
il rappelle aussi que les personnes
contaminées sont tenus informés de leur
situation et la population carcérale
informés des risques de contagion la
proportion de personnes atteintes par le
virus est forcément plus élevé en prison
du fait de l'homosexualité du fait de
l'incarcération de toxicomanes contaminé
auparavant et souvent condamnés pour vol
il faut aussi rappeler que la contagion
du sida par simple contact n'a jamais
été prouvée et que jusqu'ici seule une
petite minorité de personnes contaminées
contractent le sida la nasa en
accusation après l'explosion de
challenger de la navette américaine des
accusations qui deviennent maintenant
accablante alors que les détails d'une
enquête commencent à faire surface il
apparaît ainsi que les ennuis de
challenger avec commencé dès les
premières secondes du vol est certain
respect à certains experts sont même
persuadés qu'ils étaient prévisibles et
que nous pouvait donc les éviter les
explications de patrick esther au fur et
à mesure que la commission avance dans
son enquête
les révélations de vienne accablantes
pour la nasa ce rapport le prouvent les
ingénieurs savait que les joints en
caoutchouc des fusées d'appoint
présentait des risques graves de
défaillance l'us airforce estimé depuis
deux ans se risque à un pour 35 le 28
janvier il paraît probable que ce joint
en ce perforant et laisser des gaz
brûlants s'échapper latéralement il est
même maintenant pratiquement certain que
le phénomène ne s'est pas produit après
une minute et douze secondes de vol mais
dès le décollage sur ce document on voit
très nettement s'échapper une fumée
noire
hélas aucun système ne permettait de
prévenir
à cet instant là l'équipage
le pilote aurait-il pu réagir en
larguant les deux fusées latéral c'est
la question que pose maintenant le
public américain un peuple qui découvre
avec stupeur que la prestigieuse nasa a
failli à sa réputation
pourquoi n'at-elle pas retarder le
programme pour modifier les joies
pourquoi après leur assemblage les
fusées sont elles restées 30 jours sur
le pas de tir sans subir une seule
inspection pourquoi le tir a eu lieu
alors qu'il gelait les boosters n'était
pas prévu pour fonctionner dans de
telles conditions de basses températures
l'amérique aura des réponses à ces
questions mais il est déjà certain que
de hauts responsables devront
démissionner car si l'accident était
compréhensible la négligence ou
irresponsabilité ne le sont pas vous
allez voir maintenant des jeunes femmes
un peu d'aisé billets alors prenez votre
temps préparez vous respirez un bon coup
cas nous allons parler de lingerie
féminine comme chaque année à pareille
époque puisque c'est le salon de la
lingerie à paris vous remarquerez que
nous faisons toujours très sérieusement
c'est à dire sous l'angle économique
leur titre de cette séquence quand les
deux soupes prennent le dessus ou
comment on avant que ce qui fait plaisir
ce qui fait tant plaisir aux dames et
bien souvent messieurs le reportage sans
arrière pensée de jean marc dubois et
bruno carette
une collection ça commence par la
lecture de tous les journaux de mode
je découpe tout ce qui m'intéresse je
regarde absolument tout ce qui se fait
sur le marché et ensuite une fois j'ai
déterminé un stylet tendance que j'ai
envie de donner à ma collection
je cherche mes tissus j'ai envie de
faire comme lingerie si tu agis plus au
quotidien pour pour toutes les femmes et
ça veut dire des matières différentes
des matières plus pratique qui savent en
machine par exemple ça veut dire des
formes plus simple est étudié pour la
femme active des post it et brassière et
ça veut dire des prix aussi assez doux
bien sûr mais je veux quand même que la
femme reste sexy et désirable
non ça m'a l'air vraiment la longueur du
manche une bonne à bien par c'est bon là
ça peut partir en fabrication
et
c'est une lingerie qui va devenir un
accessoire vraiment de prêt-à-porter et
si on regardait la collection maintenant
toujours en maillot et en culotte mais
moins gracieux les footballeurs de
l'équipe de france connaissent ce soir
leur adversaire pour le championnat
d'europe des nations ce sera en 1988
ils affronteront pour les éliminatoires
des gros morceaux comme une eau society
coup l'allemagne de l'est mais aussi des
pays qui sont moins redoutable comme la
norvège ou l'islande c'est en tout cas
un tirage qui est quand même très
difficile pour les tricolores
et puis en sport un mot du rallye de
suède pour vous annoncer l'abandon de
timo salonen qui occupaient une
confortable première place sur sa 205
turbo
il a donc été contraint aujourd'hui à la
vente un coup de jeune pour le vieux
colombier refermer qui était fermée
depuis 15 ans ce théâtre prestigieux qui
fuit et qui vit la gloire de comédiens
du calibre de copeaux de jouvet ou de
dullin le vieux colombier rouvre ses
portes et change de vie le voici
transformé en théâtre école de l'europe
avec une particularité c'est la première
fois en france qu'un théâtre est racheté
par un ministère en l'occurrence le
ministère de la culture
voici le reportage de ces leviers marion
et de jacques auberton quiconque aime et
connaît l'histoire du théâtre ne peut
qu'être ému en voyant cette pauvre salle
à l'abandon et ne peut que se réjouir en
apprenant qu'elle va revivre
car ici au vieux colombier et met tout
le théâtre contemporain français la
magie des lieux tient à un nom jacques
copeau le premier aux côtés de charles
dullin et de louis jouvet à avoir entamé
dans les années 20 une rupture avec le
théâtre de boulevard et le théâtre
classique pour créer le théâtre moderne
rigoureux que nous connaissons à part
tout le temps qui est passé après tout
les couleurs qui sont sages et après
tout les ravages du temps inévitable ces
lieux a un charme et maintient un
espèce d'esprit étrange qui est restée
la grimpée euros au mur et danser en
laissant tout ce que ces lieux et on tue
peu hanté par la présence des quelque
chose ssl c'est la présence déjà coupons
pour moi personne mieux que la
comédienne mariée linda stahl ne peut
parler avec amour du travail de jacques
copeau son père j'ai assisté à ce qui a
été la consécration du vieux colombier
qui était son premier succès c'était
l'amour mais là non c'était la nuit des
rois de shakespeare et ça c'était une
fête c'était une c'était la poésie rendu
palpable rendu sensible par les couleurs
par la lumière par une sorte de
vibrations absolument indescriptible qui
était la poésie il faudra deux ans de
travaux pour que le vieux colombier
retrouve sa façade ça ce n est que le
théâtre école de l'europe dirigé par
giorgio strehler ouvre ses portes sans
transition du vieux colombier à
l'hippodrome d'enghien pour les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé de demain vous allez les voir
s'inscrire sur votre écran voilà il ya
vingt partants 1-2 vous suggère de jouer
le 18 le neuf le 11 le 3 le vin las le
14 le 4 je répète 18,9
11 3-20 as et 14
beaucoup de monde sur les routes de ce
week end pour une nouvelle vague de
migration hivernale toujours la même
histoire le chassé croisé de ceux qui
rentrent et de ceux qui partent prudence
donc soyez calme soyez patient soyez
éventuellement bienveillant d'autant que
la région rhône alpes était sous la
neige aujourd'hui le temps maintenant
avec laurent boussier d'abord la neige
sur la région de grenoble et une
circulation très difficile dans toute la
région rhône alpes dont coup le réseau
routier secondaire a été pratiquement
bloquée pendant toute la journée
il faut dire que la neige est tombée en
abondance la nuit dernière et que dans
certains départements comme l'ardèche et
il est tombé plus de trois mètres
cinquante de neige en
moi heureusement grâce aux importants
moyens mis en oeuvre les routes
principales les autoroutes et les accès
aux stations de sports d'hiver sont ce
soir généralement dégagé cela dit demain
est un jour difficile sur toutes les
routes de montagne et la sécurité
routière vous donne des informations par
bison fûté la sécurité routière qui vous
demande de ne pas quitter les stations
de ski entre 8h du matin et 16 heures 8
heures et 16 heures si c'est possible
essayer de partir avant
sinon essayez de partir après ce qui est
ennuyeux si vous voulez c'est que la
situation ne s'arrange pas vraiment que
la neige le verglas et les autres seront
encore là demain
regardez la photo satellite il ya deux
petites dépressions l'une sur le golfe
de gênes sur la méditerranée et l'autre
sur sur large tout à fait au large de la
de la bretagne autour de ces dépressions
s'enroule des nuages dans les deux sens
des plages qui vont qui viennent qui
reviennent la seule chose qui est sûre
c'est que beaucoup de nuages arrivent
sur la france beaucoup de nuages
stationnent sur la france regardez la
carte du temps pris nouveau demain ils
sont encore là très nombreux
malheureusement sur toute la région
rhône alpes sur l'est du massif central
sur les alpes un petit peu sur la
franche comté
il y aura des voitures il y aura des
nuages et de la neige donc attention il
y aura aussi d'ailleurs
du verglas sur la moitié nord du pays
après une matinée encore relativement
clair les nuages vont arriver avec
quelques éclaircies c'est vrai avec des
averses aussi et puis des chutes de
neige même à basse altitude même en
plein surtout le nord-est du pays seules
régions où le temps valait un tout petit
peu mieux c'est surtout le sud-ouest du
pays tant grill matane qui deviendra
plus clair l'après midi avec de belles
éclaircies
le tout avec des vents de sud-ouest
modéré pour le moment en tout cas
côté températures elles sont encore en
légère hausse est la seule bonne
nouvelle pour le week-end et le
resteront quand même négatif sur sur
l'extrême nord-est sur strasbourg sur
mulhouse sur nancy - 1° mais elles sont
positives sur tout le reste du pays 4° à
fait riper un maximum de 7 degrés à
brest c'est quand même agréable sur la
moitié sud 3 degrés à lyon et puis
jusqu'à 15 degrés même 15 degrés à
biarritz voyez c'est tout à fait
agréable ça revient ça revient
heureusement me direz-vous parce qu'on
était vraiment descendu très très bas
demain c'est samedi samedi 15 février le
soleil se lève à 8h01 se couche à 18h09
ça nous fait trois minutes de soleil en
plus
et c'est la saint claude alors bonne
fête lui
dernière information dernier commentaire
aux environs de 22 heures 50 avec daniel
leconte après apostrophe demain votre
premier rendez vous de l'information et
à 12h pour à nous deux et puis ça
servait claude à 12h45 pour antenne dès
midi bonsoir admirateurs
oui